let's take a step back so the reason
that we do that is so we can have more
authentic relationships and not be
looking at our phone like you said when
you're at a restaurant when they open up
back up I love that idea you know you
everybody stacks their phone and the
first person to look at it
pays the bill that's fantastic paying
the bill yeah yeah you know we need to
get back to these face to face to
actually listening to people and hearing
them and being heard hi my name is Peter
Bogosian from the don't burn this book
club with Dave Rubin and this is chapter
10 move on with your life and it is a
genuine pleasure to do this I love the
book I love chapter 10 and and I'm just
gonna jump right in Dave and I'm gonna
ask you some questions
so first what in your opinion one of the
things that you said in the book that's
been tormenting me since I wrote it was
how you put away your devices and you
get off the grid tell me a bit yeah how
did you how do you do that I mean like
even my phone I even use as an alarm to
wake me up I don't have an alarm clock I
look at the time how do you do that you
also mention you know don't don't put
your phone in your in your room because
the the bedroom isn't for that how do
you get started with that yeah so first
off I just want to say thank you for
doing this Pete and you were when we
looked at the 10 people that I wanted to
hit these 10 chapters I knew that you
were the guy I wanted to do chapter 10
with because I think our friendship and
I think the things that you've tried to
put out into the world for whatever our
minor political disagreements might be
are you want to live in the same place
that I want to live in and you've stood
up to the mob in so many ways for those
that don't know you know you you're up
in Portland that's not an easy place for
an anti social justice warrior
freethinker to be so you've been in the
thick of it so to answer your question
specifically well look first off you
know I lay out a couple tips and tricks
you can do to get rid of the phone
because you know right now although I
wrote this obviously before coronavirus
it's like we were all obsessed with the
digital life and being
Tech was already in control of so much
of our information before Corona and now
we're in lockdown and you know well it
looks like it in certain states probably
our two states we're gonna be in this
thing for quite some time big tech and
and Twitter and YouTube and videos and
information it has more of a hold on us
right now than it had two months ago
when it already had too much control of
us so I do lay out a couple tips I mean
one thing you know you might have to get
an alarm Pete I know it feels very
old-school but like yeah we all you we
all use our phone now as the alarm so
that means you probably bring it into
your bedroom but one of the things that
I found we all do but one of the things
that I found is if you bring that thing
into your bedroom it will be the last
thing you look at at night and it will
be the first thing that you look at in
the morning and for guys like us
especially it is not good to start your
day and open up Twitter and having an
anime pink fox tell you that you're you
know you're not yeah bet your Hitler in
essence that's not what you should eat
that's not what you should be seeing
before you go to bed so I do believe
that the bedroom I don't we don't have a
television in our bedroom either I mean
I believe that the bedroom is basically
for sex and sleeping you could probably
add a couple other little things in
there you can read read a book in the in
bed that's good or on your Kindle but I
think figuring out the little moments to
detach from all of this is is just super
important right and and so let's take a
step back so the reason that we do that
is so we can have more authentic
relationships and not be looking at our
phone like you said when you're at a
restaurant when they opened up back up I
love that idea you know you everybody
stacks their phone and the first person
to look at it pays the bill that's
fantastic okay and the bill yeah yeah
you know we need to get back to these
face-to-face to actually listening to
people and hearing them and being heard
my problem though is like so I I'm
trying to walk 12,500 steps a day and I
was thinking well geez I'll leave my
phone but if I left my phone I wouldn't
listen to your podcast or a podcast or a
music do you know what I'm saying it's
like they're all the phone is so
integrated into our lives but yet
and you're right you mentioned in the
book that it's an addiction I think we
all have a low-grade or some people have
a high-grade addiction when you what
advice can you give people to really
bracket technology in their lives like
you've gone off the grid for like what
do you what advice could we know why you
should do it to re-inject the humanism
in our relationships how do you get
started with that I can't because I I
try to figure that out I don't know how
to do it I think the first thing is
realize that we don't have to be
endlessly entertained or amused so
you're you're a dog guy you've got a
couple of dogs one of the things that I
do Clyde sitting right here right now
when I take him out for a walk I do not
take my phone so yes that means I am not
listening to a podcast I have a lot of
friends who are podcasters there's
podcasts that I enjoy but I'm not
listening to a podcast I'm not looking
at my phone I'm not waiting for emails
to roll in and we take a walk and you
know it's so funny because that sounds
like a unique thing my god you walk your
dog with no device it sounds like some
some sort of crazy thing that is how we
all lived a mere 20 years ago let's not
forget I got my first cell phone it was
a little Nokia one of those little bars
that all you could do was play snake I
got that thing in 2000 that's when I got
my first phone only 20 years ago so part
of the issue related to tech and why we
all sort of feel crazy all the time and
you know sometimes you're on your phone
and you and your wife or your husband
whatever it is is literally talking to
you and you hear them talking but you
don't respond and we're all guilty of
this you and there you go what could you
repeat that and it's like man that's
what people do in there when they're 80
and 90 and I think it's I think it's
done all sorts of stuff to rewire us to
short out our attention span and all of
these things so I think partly I think
the first step is just realizing but
just because we have this stuff doesn't
mean we should need it all the time now
I say that as someone I admit this in
chapter 10 I have a terrible sense of
direction so when I went off the grid in
August well I still do have GPS in my
car so I did it's not that I had no
screen whatsoever but even on the news
front you know it's like I've taken
these last three August where I do no
nudes and guess what you don't miss my
now August is a little down anyway the
year before last I believe it was when
John McCain died I didn't hear about
that the you know there there was like a
three weeks of hearing about Michael
Cohen testimony against Trump it's like
you realize that these things are
actually we feel like they're so
important on any given moment at all and
then you realize it doesn't really
matter and that's why I start the
chapter with a story about the
Australian woman I'm just going to say
that yeah yeah you started the chapter
with a with with something that we've
all heard about hospice day and what
people value toward their end of the
life their lives and what gives their
lives meaning and I want to know so when
you do go off the grid and when you
don't talk to people and you have your
advice do you feel that you gain more
meaning yes and and you feel more
closely connected yeah yes I feel more
patient I feel more calm I know you know
I'm pretty friendly and you know fairly
outgoing in general but like I know that
when I'm at a store I'm friendlier with
the cashier yeah you know like normally
you could go to a cashier you're on
Twitter the whole time you don't even
look you don't even in some ways you
don't even realize it's a human but when
you go there without a phone oh hi how
are you nice to see you again how's your
day going and then people start looking
show you
right in sliminess question sir then for
you in your life the thinking that gives
the most meaning is that is that your
interactions of people like your
relationships with people like your
relationships with your husband and your
friends and is that ultimately to you
where it what it's about you know I
think ultimately that is what it's about
you know I've had a lot of time just
like everybody else to think about my
life well we're in quarantine here and
one of the things that I've been
thinking about is I'm very satisfied and
I would say blessed and lucky that like
I live in the house that I want to live
in I don't really want any physical
things we don't have a ton of stuff but
we have the thing that we share one car
the nice car but like I don't want more
cars I don't want like there aren't they
there really aren't like physical things
that I want now that's not to say I
don't want to be more successful I don't
want to continue to enrich my mind and
continue to have an influence in all of
the things that we do but my my
relationship with my partner is pretty
great I've been working harder even
through writing this I think it's made
me a better person so I've been working
harder at some of the inter personal
family stuff and that kind of thing
and I think a lot of people are feeling
this right now you know in the midst of
quarantine it hit me the other day like
it'll be really nice when I can like see
my parents again and hug them just
literally hug them like we FaceTime all
the time but just just to hug them and
you know I know you lost your dad the
last couple in you know in the last few
years and it's like it's like we all
forget that like this is just temporary
and we're so caught up in nonsense that
that's why I started the first chat the
the chapter like that talking about this
woman taking care of these hospice
patients because nobody said I wanted to
be at work more nobody said I wish I had
paid more attention to politics nobody
said oh I should have been fighting with
my neighbor more every single person
said I should have followed my passion
more I should have done what I wanted to
do I should have followed that love that
I let get away and all those things and
it's like we know this this is not
rocket science we know it right so let
me ask you a question you know one of
the things that the theme that emerges
is let friends be wrong and you have
friends people you have significant
political disagreements with
there's joy your friends and for some
people that idea is just like a toxin
like like they just that's they're just
incredulous I my guesses would be with
folks who are younger how do you
navigate those differences with your
friends if they have different because
your political guy and you think about
this stuff how do you navigate those
differences with your friends people who
have substantive maybe I guess how do
you do that in other beliefs that people
have that would be a deal-breaker for
you in your relationship you know
there's a guy that I know that wrote a
book I have it right over here it's
called how to have impossible
conversations it's a pretty it's a
pretty good read and you're somebody
that's been trying to do this and you go
to public places sometimes and you
welcome people to argue with you and
counterpoint with you and all that I
actually don't think that our position
on this to agree to disagree is really
against what most people believe I think
the people that don't believe it right
now or let's say the people who are so
angry all the time and try to deep
platform us I mean we've done we've done
events together where we had protesters
calling us Nazis and try to shut down
the event and call you know firearms and
all thing I don't think they really
believe it i I think they're scared and
I also think that their their set of
ideas is so conflicting and so
compounding and and I always say this
it's many ways it's anti human you know
this idea of social justice and this
idea of grouping people it's anti human
because what's human is to be an
individual right you're you're Peter
Bogosian who should be judged on your
ideas and actions and thoughts you're
not just oh middle-aged white guy must
think this and I think what happens why
so many of them go crazy is because once
you take a set a set of ideas and apply
it to yourself that is actually against
you it's against you as a person as an
individual you start getting more
hysterical so what I try to do and it is
why I take it's why I started doing the
off-the-grid thing and why I try not to
tweet on the weekends which I've haven't
done that well during coronavirus
because the week end is sort of the week
and the weekend of like blended into one
endless thing but the reason that I try
to do it is we shouldn't always be doing
this
we should you shouldn't feel oh man it's
why I only do one or two shows a week by
the way people always say to me Dave why
don't you do five interviews a week now
I know we could do more and I'd make
more money and we could do all that kind
of stuff and it's not for a lack of
working I bust my ass every second of
the day it's because I don't want to
keep it I don't want to keep hitting
people with this stuff it's like if you
give me an hour of your week if I have
one solid interview with whoever it
might be and you give me an hour of your
week well then I assume you might have
given sam harris some time in your week
you might have given joe rogan some time
in your week the litany of other people
and not just politics and and you know
whatever you do and it's like I want
people to do all those other things care
about the world but care about yourself
first I think I think that really is the
message and that makes you less
attentive to the people you have of if
you're cramming in more people right so
it makes you it makes those interactions
I would think less you'd be less present
for them is that right well absolutely
and you know the other thing here and I
think this is probably a very Jordan
Peterson notion and I know that since
you read the book you know chapter 9 and
the way that Jordan has affected me but
you know a lot of times I'll see because
we all get so much hate online and it's
just it's just evolved into something
that it wasn't supposed to be you know
it's supposed to be social media make us
social and we're social creatures and we
all thought it was gonna build something
amazing and not not to say it hasn't
look look at our lives how they've been
enriched do we know each other because
of this thing my show I mean I'm not
denying that it's been good but I would
say social media and the internet it you
know it's like fire fire can cook and it
can warm you up and it can also burn the
house down and kill the family so you
know it's sort of like that but one of
the things that I see which is why I
think getting out of this thing is
important is that all the people that
are sort of the endless haters the the
all the anonymous accounts and the
people that just want to destroy all the
time and silence everybody it's like you
know if you guys would just clean your
room
that's what Jordans message was meaning
I would guarantee you that most of the
people that spend all day long sowing
chaos across the internet it's because
whatever
internal stuff is and we've all had it
right we've all had it we all have it
but if you don't solve your internal
stuff you will send the world into chaos
and and that's why I think his message
really resonated with so many people
because it was like set some order in
your life and then you might set some
order in the world and and I think
partly not being obsessed with the
online adventure and understanding that
were organic creatures in a real world I
think that's part of how you do it
alright let me ask you two questions two
to finishing questions about the process
of writing the book what did you learn
from the process of writing this book
because I know the people are out there
listening like these I I'd like to write
a book I mean what have you learned from
this well I love that you're asking me
that
well first off if you're thinking about
writing a book just start doing it I
know it sounds simple like it's like
like what kind of advice is that it's
like I want to write a book yeah start
doing okay no but it's like really
just like sit down and sit at that
computer and and pump out a couple
things that you think are important and
then see if you can just make them into
even essays whatever they are you know
everyone has a different process you
were one of the people that I called
every now and again to kind of work
through an issue as as they were coming
what I realized for me is my process I
would I would get up in the morning Emma
Emma our previous dog was still alive
but she was in her her last days I would
get her out to pee she'd come into there
she'd come into the room with me and
she'd lay there and I'd have my coffee
and then I would go and it would be at
about 7:00 a.m. usually and I could go
sometimes till like 2:00 p.m. without
stopping sometimes forgetting to eat
I've been telling people David would
literally open up the door slide like a
sandwich in on a plate as if I was in
maximum confine you know maximum
security prison and sometimes I wouldn't
even eat that I could go and go and go
and then when I hit the wall I was done
I would not start again at five o'clock
if I would go and but but everyone's
process is different some writers I'm
sure yours is different like do it is
your main piece of advice just sit down
and do it allocates or whatever your way
is right I'm not here to tell you oh you
have to do it yeah precisely I'm not
here to tell you you have to do it my
way I'm sure your way Pete of writing is
different than mine maybe you picked it
up
times during the day maybe you'd have a
week where you wrote hardcore and then
you take a week off whatever that might
be you have to do what works in your
brain what works in your rhythm with the
world but what I really did love about
it that I didn't know is the discipline
of doing it it forced me to think
through my issues better to really
understand why I thought the things and
I gotta tell you man
when the box arrived then you see this
thing you see this physical thing and
you're like amazing I did that and that
has you know Clyde lit Clyde literally
ate the box of the first copy and the
first colony of my book eaten by the dog
so here we are that's not a referendum
on the book though did you did you is
there anything that you became that you
changed your mind about when you wrote
the book or is there anything that you
and I meant asking these questions
because this is we're doing chapter 10
and it's the conclusion of the book is
there anything that you became more
convinced of through the process of
thinking about it and writing the book
gosh you know the chapter let me see you
know truly the the key to this was
really making sure that what I say and
what I've been preaching on the show and
on Twitter and everywhere else is really
what I believe that that really was the
key to the whole thing and I did find
myself challenging some of my thoughts
so I the hardest one for me to write in
many ways was the abortion chapter
because or the section abortion because
because you know I think you're probably
feeling a certain version of this too as
the left has gone so off the deep end on
the pro-choice side meaning 8-month
abortions let's talk about post birth
abortions I mean just sort of all sorts
of stuff and you're pro-choice right yes
yeah so but as sort of let's say our
team or our old team whatever you want
to call that as they've sort of lost any
sense of what would be moderate and by
the way you know when I interviewed
several of the candidates that the more
moderate candidates tulsi gabbard andrew
yang when I asked them about abortion
they really wouldn't say the well yang
particularly wouldn't give me a cutoff
point tulsi sort of said the first
trimester thing which i think is fair
and that's the position I lay out in the
book and by the way I make a point of
saying I do believe it's a life but we
have to have some parameters to have all
sorts of people with all sorts of
thoughts in the world in the in the
country to to have some sort of cohesive
society so I really had to challenge
myself through that one and as you know
you know we're in the process of
surrogacy now so we're looking at egg
donors and we were we were getting our
surrogate and all that so it's like I
was intimately involved I mean I'm
literally going to the to the clinic to
donate sperm and they're talking to us
about how they're gonna take that and
put it with the egg and then put it in
the surrogate and all these things I was
literally going through that as I was
writing it and I would liken that to
when people ask me about my my
libertarian economic beliefs and low
government a little government and or
small government I should say and low
taxes and things like that it's like
those ideas they were first ideas for me
but then as you know I've built a really
nice small business here
and I've been able to treat my employees
well and I love that and my guys work
hard for me and we try to take care of
them and I know that if I live in one of
the highest taxed most regulated states
in the country if not if not the highest
on both fronts and I know that if the
government would actually cut my taxes I
could pay my guys more or hire more
people so I think really the rubber met
the road I think as I wrote this I
started going whoa these issues that I
talked about they're not just things I
talk about now Clyde's freaking out
they're not just things that I talk
about they're actually they're actually
ideas that I've put into place in my own
life and I'm very proud of that oh good
good well speaking of dogs you know we
adopted a dog too she's she's right here
in barking so it's easy if you can hear
so it what is the thing they were coming
up to the end of our 20 minutes I think
we're yeah they're she's in on it too
boy
mostly people just what yeah she what a
beauty what a beauty and you got her
because of the lockdown I love that I
love that yeah we got it for my daughter
we the day that we got her this
parenthetical isn't in the day that we
got her literally the day Dave she
became sick and had to go to the ICU and
it cost us $1,000 a day for seven days
but but she's great she's been a joy and
she's part of the family she's wonderful
okay so chapter 10 I love the advice
about the devices I love the advice
about thinking back about regrets and
what is the most meaningful things in
our lives and I'm gonna try to do that I
think I will get an alarm clock I
thought I was gonna ask you about that
and I think I will be because I noticed
that when I have my devices I'm less
present even like at the dog park or
walking the dog or I do think it takes
something meaningful out of those
relationships and it makes you less
mindful in the moment as well so I think
that there are some some things that we
can all benefit from and I also like the
I want to reiterate if people are
thinking about writing a book I think
your advice is fantastic you just have
to do it
don't your perfection is the enemy have
done don't get caught up and this stuff
just sit down and and I'll add to what
you said by telling people in your life
I'm committed to this I'm gonna write a
book so like you have support husband
who slid the you know food to you and so
I think if you tell people in your life
like I want to write a book this means
something to me and then I like the idea
that when you said that you thought
about and reflect on like abortion or
things in your life that when you write
off and it can help clarify or
crystallize things what do you want to
leave people with after they read again
I'm seeing geez me answer this question
which is chapter 10 people read this
what do you want to leave them with what
I truly would I want to leave them with
and I try to say this at the end and it
was exactly why I had the length that I
had and everything else is that I wanted
people to be able to read this thing in
a couple days I'd want I wanted them to
start thinking about the issues that I
talked about I wanted to give them some
tricks and tips to stand up to the mob I
wanted them to be brave enough to
fight for what they believe in they
don't have you don't have to agree with
me like I know a lot of conservatives
are not going to agree with me on
abortion right like we know that and
that and that's okay by the way and by
and by the way I'm getting a ton of
email right now from conservatives who
are saying Dave I love the book love
everything in it but you're wrong on
abortion and we'll get you one day but
they do it kindly and nicely and that's
a beautiful thing but what I want more
than anything else is for someone that
reads this book if it hits you in any
way I know that means that there's
someone in your life that you should
hand this thing to and if you hand it to
if you hand it to them with some grace
and and not Club them over the head with
it but just say you know this was sort
of interesting the guy kind of agrees
with you on this this this and this but
you might not agree with this they might
read it and then maybe maybe we can
start fixing this thing and I think
we're already doing it but our work is
cut out for us yeah you know I when I
opened the book thank you that the the
your remarks were totally lovely excuse
me when I when I opened the book and I
saw that it was devoted to Ben Affleck I
I couldn't stop laughing
and I want to bookmark that with the
last thing that that you wrote the last
line because I think it's so true it's a
book started humorous humorously it made
me laugh and it just made me think
through the whole way and it's just such
a clear it's just so clear the last
thing you write the last sentence is
thinking for yourself is all you need in
an age of unreason I mean that is so
perfect so true and so profound at the
same time but yet it's so difficult for
all of us right to think universai
right to be honest with ourselves to be
sincere with other people to be
forthright in our speech to say what we
mean and like what you say to make sure
that what you say in the show and the
book and you live what you do it's that
idea that you judge a person we ought to
be judged at least by what we say
against what we do and I think that
there's something there's a timeless
message in that of thinking we every
every age that we have has some we all
are like myopic right we all think that
some value the values that we have now
are you know universal timeless values
but the key is you said it in the books
it's the theme throughout the whole book
it's thinking for yourself and what that
means it how to be honest with yourself
right I mean that's it my friend that
was why as every other often author in
the history of the world
I wrote the final sentence about 80
times changed you know it was like the
same idea 80 times over and I'm like
this is it no this is it could this be
funny or no it's a little too serious
emphasis on this word but that's what
that was the takeaway the takeaway was
you don't have to buy everything that
I'm selling figure it out for yourself
and that's it figure out for yourself
and if someone comes to a different
conclusion that's okay too that's that's
the beginning of the conversation that's
it I can't I can't stress it enough
truly fantastic and it's an honor to be
with you and talk to that Dave thank you
so much and thank for you for your
friendship and what you do thank you
right back at your brother I'll see you
soon hopefully in real life we'll
eventually in real life right maybe one
day perhaps I'm looking forward to it
thanks Dave
you're a good man all right be good if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlists they're right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell